[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
tuesday july 12th i'm zoe thomas for the
wall street journal
google's massive ad tech business has
been the target of legal and anti-trust
investigations
for years the alphabet-owned company has
controlled a significant portion of the
online ad market all along the chain
now sources say google has offered
concessions in an attempt to head off a
possible u.s anti-trust lawsuit
last week the wall street journal
exclusively reported the moves by google
a sign of just how intense pressure on
the tech giant has become
joining us to discuss what google is
offering and what it could mean for
anti-trust concerns is our tech reporter
sam schechner hi sam thanks for coming
on the show great to be here
so sam you've been speaking with people
familiar with google's plans
what concessions is the company offering
to make
well according to at least one offer
that the company has made to the us
department of justice
the company would split parts of the
business its ad tech business that
auctions and places ads and websites and
apps into a separate company that's
owned by umbrella it wouldn't be an
asset sale or a divestiture of
those
parts of that business as some
detractors have been
asking for
but it would be a restructuring
internally of how that business is
operated and what would that mean for
how google makes money off of ads well
that is a great question and the honest
answer is we don't know until we see the
details if this offer becomes something
that actually goes into practice we know
that google plays a central role in the
business of brokering ads across the
internet you know advertisers are slated
to spend more than 600 billion on
digital ads worldwide this year and
google's business
brokering those ads accounted for about
12 percent of its total revenue of 31
billion dollars or closer to 32 actually
last year so that's a huge business so
any changes they make to how that
operates and any
concessions they might make to
you know give
other companies a bigger share that pi
would be significant
are u.s regulators likely to accept this
offer
well
what people familiar with the matter
have told us is that antitrust officials
in the u.s have a preference for deep
structural changes things like asset
sales or divestitures rather than
promises to change business practices
what are so-called behavioral remedies
so the fact that this wouldn't involve
google selling parts of its ad tech
business and in fact google told us they
have no plans to sell or exit this
business
might make it a tougher sell to the doj
that remains to be seen
you know google isn't only facing
pressure though from u.s regulators
they're facing pressure globally europe
has raised concerns about its ad
business how are they receiving this
news and how is google dealing with
concerns over in europe
well you're right that concerns about
google's role in advertising technology
as a broker and
auction house for digital ads
has raised concern in many jurisdictions
around the world that's something that
not only is the u.s looking at but the
eu is also investigating it as is the uk
the eu opened its investigation last
year
and you know they've talked about the
concerns they have that google might be
preferencing its own business and one of
the big complaints that they've been
looking into
is that it's not possible to buy ads on
youtube one of the
world's biggest online video platforms
if not the biggest unless you use
google's advertising tools and so what
people familiar with the matter have
told us
is that google has actually
made an offer
there as well in which it would allow
competitors to broker the sales of ads
directly on youtube and that could help
address at least that part of the eu's
investigation into google's advertising
technology business
let's back up a bit because you
mentioned you know just how large
google's ad business has become but how
did it get so big and how are these
concerns and the pressure on it been
mounting over the last couple of years
well you know it's actually a long story
and if you talk to google detractors and
some google competitors they'd say the
original sin is that antitrust
officials allowed google to buy a
company called doubleclick they made an
agreement to do that back in 2007 and
the deal closed the following year and
doubleclick
was a service that served ads to
websites and used the data on those
sites to serve those ads and also you
know had an
ad auctioning business and that helped
give google immense scale and there's
been a series of transactions like that
that have helped the company build scale
and so
the idea is that if you want to buy an
ad on the internet you know on an app or
on a website you can use google tools to
buy that ad to place the buy if you're
an ad buyer and then those tools might
seek out the ad and make a bid on an
auction platform that's owned by google
and the bid requests the ads that are
being auctioned on that platform might
be provided as well by a google tool
that's then built into the app or
website so they could control all of
what's called the ad tech stack now
there are other companies that are
involved in this kind of very
complicated network of buying and
selling ads within milliseconds across
the internet
but the fact that google owns every step
of that process
has led to complaints complaints that
google
rejects but complaints that the company
you know has a conflict of interest or
maybe self-dealing or taking too big a
share of
online advertising profits
i mean given how involved how
intertwined it is in all of those layers
are these concessions likely to change
things for competitors or for customers
significantly
that is the question
that anti-trust enforcers are going to
have to ask themselves as they prepare
this
lawsuit in the u.s
are google's
offers and concessions on the table
sufficient to address their concerns
and will it make it a difference to the
advertising ecosystem or by contrast do
they think it's not sufficient and do
they want to take their chances fighting
what could be a protracted court battle
with no guarantee that they'll actually
prevail at the end
all right that's our reporter sam
schechner thanks for breaking this down
for us sam my pleasure
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want more tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
and if you like our show please rate and
review it you can do that wherever you
get your podcasts
i'm zoe thomas for the wall street
journal thanks for listening
[Music]
you